[Musique]
je vais régler ça
on
attention tout le monde plante est en 15
secondes
[Musique]
les gens croient qu'on a simulé sa mort
tu fais quoi dans la voiture ada ilana
m'a dit que l'audience a chuté
les gens doivent sûrement s'ennuyer faut
augmenter les enjeux à dents tu as fait
quoi dans la voiture rien du tout en
fait cette femme est bien morte sur le
plateau je veux plus voir de moroni eux
sur le bateau il faut surprendre
tu oublies pourquoi ils veulent mourir
c'est pas ça le plus important
[Musique]
non rien
vas-y avance tout droit au la vache
oui ça tu peux le dire regarde ici c'est
ma pièce préférée y avoir chez moi tu
vois cette petite maison là bas deux
chambres cuisine équipée et ton nom sur
la porte
c'est pas les moyens tu crois que je
vais te faire payer un loyer
tu peux y rester gratuitement aussi
longtemps que tu veux tu as juste à
économiser pour acheter ta maison adam
j'ai un crédit à rembourser 200 mille
dollars avant de penser à acheter une
maison se met d'accord ce qui fait
penser à s'il te plaît c'est pas pour
que tu sois riche c'est pour remettre
les compteurs à zéro je peux pas dans ça
fait trois mois que je t'ai pas vu tu es
mon seul ami oui je sais je sais excuse
moi j'ai été vraiment débordés tu te
regarder en face tu as vu ce que c'est
cette maison c'est du délire oui oui tu
veux dire dans le sens que c'est cool
parce que non parce que je suis non non
à dents je plaisante pas et ton fric tu
peux te le garder pour toi tu es ma
soeur karine à je t'aime beaucoup et tu
as bien remonté la pente et et j'étais
promis un jour que je m'occuperai bien
je sais mais à quel prix à quel prix
combien de gens sont morts ont dû mourir
pour que tu es cette maison
pour ce chèque 10 30
ça montre que je ne sois pas ridicule à
mort est ridicule pour toi maintenant je
sais ce que je fais comme boulot n'est
pas ridicule il suffit de regarder mon
émission tu verrais que je prends mon
travail très au sérieux en montrant la
mort je suis peut-être le seul face aux
gens à changer leur approche de la vie
le monde se réveille nuit sans
présentateur qui présente un jeu
télévisé c'est tout fois revestois un
peu
[Musique]
emma notre présentateur merci
alors j'ai eu une conversation sérieuse
et intéressante avec ma soeur
aujourd'hui et au nom de la transparence
j'ai pensé la partager avec vous que ce
que nous faisons ici est abominable non
non
une je comprends tous avoir un avis
divergent caméra 3d ce qui m'a fait mal
on sait qu'elle est appelée ce un jeu
télévisé comme si oui si la seule chose
en jeu ici ne pouvait être que la rhune
oui ça me fait mal de nos remarques et
réfléchie pouvoir indélicate a envers
moi mais envers ce qui t'arrive en
donnent leur vie pour une grosse
supérieur et le fait que cela vienne de
ma professeure le seul membre de ma
famille qui me restent sur cette plaine
quand les choses peut-être plus
douloureuse
restez avec nous vous allez mourir ce
soir revient juste après ces quelques
messages ans et la pub alors la personne
suivante ce sera une pendaison
donc je veux monde sur luc faisant
exploser l'audimat vous êtes la protégée
de tout le monde maintenant je suis fier
de vos mademoiselle c'est le sentiment
qui m'honore après il faudra resserrer
sur lui messieurs il ya un changement de
plein ce soir celui qui devait se pendre
à fait faux bond et bien sûr vous ne
pensez à le dire qu'une minute avant
lentilles à penser mais j'ai décidé de
pas le faire il y aura peu de mouvements
un plein sur plateau et tenez c'est le
script prompteur d'adam je gomme
inquiéter ou wii vous devriez sûrement
[Applaudissements]
ici dans vous allez mourir ce soir nous
avons toute l'année était en mission en
mission pour sortir notre pays de son
extrême à différence de son grand
sommeil pour lui faire comprendre et
vivre la réalité de ce qui existe et ce
soir ce ne sera pas une exception
je vous demande maintenant d'accueillir
notre courage aux invités suivante
karina au cou c'est quoi ça l'est c'est
cette vidéo je ne veux pas lancer cette
vidéo keller c'est mon équipe et simon
il si vous lancez cette vidéo keller il
y aura plus de missions plus de saisons
de plus de vente à d'autres diffuseurs
plus de ventes internationales plus rien
du tout parfait mais je rappelle à tout
le monde connaît toujours en direct
keller je peux pas le croire
je m'appelle carmes la rogers c'est pas
très malin je suis la jeune soeur d'adam
votre jeune présentateur et co créateur
de l'émission
par quoi vous jouez l'instant à donner
moi sont revenus encore plus proche que
de simples frais certes mes parents ont
été tuées par un chauffard alcoolisé
j'avais 15 ans rina et à dans 20 ans
prévert tous les est tombé s'occuper à
moi et si bien je souffre car il a des
dépressions nerveuses karina
vous êtes un monstre et blanc non je
suis votre protégé vous vous souvenez
vigueur qu'est ce qui lie à bernis
écoutez moi j'ai tout le comité
directeur en ligne je vous en prie dites
moi que c'est une plaisanterie en
croyant qu'ils pouvaient changer
il la fait pas de la façon je pense ou
qu'ils espéraient
pourquoi faites vous cela arrêter là et
je vais faire pour tous
personne ne me regarde ressentir de la
sympathie
et pour être un est violemment dans la
réalité
regarder pour voir comment je vais
mettre fin à mes jours
[Musique]
il ne faut plus de morts après mois
karina est ya personne pour l'arrêter et
merde et fait arrêter là les gars
arrêtez là
nous voici de nouveau parmi vous pour
poursuivre l'émission en direct de
concurrentes sont encore en course mais
une seule va bientôt épouser un
millionnaire j'ai décidé d'épouser
prendre
[Applaudissements]
que ressentons quand on est devenu comme
vous un héros national suis pas un héros
je n'ai fait que ce que tout le monde
aurait fait dans ces circonstances rares
de la plupart des gens se seraient
enfuis ce qu'il s'est passé dans votre
émission est un vrai désastre
mais légalement ni le groupe wpc ni les
producteurs ne peuvent être tenus
responsables donc si nous avions une
émission en direct des gens comme était
un suicide
vous ne serez pas en bonne voie
ras-le-bol d'exploiter les gens pour
faire de l'audience
si effectivement les gens meurent je
veux tu meurs pour une bonne raison
trentaine d'enfants
y'a 3
ce que vous allez voir ce soir est
différent de tout ce que vous avez vu à
la télévision vous serez probablement
choqué
sarah hickey ne pourra plus avoir de
nouvelles vies mais sa fille pourrait
vous n'avez qu'une chose à faire c'est
faute et on a offert 300 mille dollars à
cit fils
tout le monde à la télé n'est pas riche
et beau et ne vit pas rêve américain ce
sont des gens comme nous ils sont
pauvres et sans espoir coûté jeune femme
il y fait bientôt perdre ma maison je
ferai tout ce que vous demandez vous
comprenez ce n'est pas le soir
[Musique]
c'est
et
merci d'avoir regardé vous allez mourir
ce soir
la vie est précieuse
iv l'apaisement
[Musique]